the defendant is not guilty former
Florida sheriff's deputy Scott Peterson
visibly shook as the jury in his trial
cleared him of charges including felony
child neglect culpable negligence and
perjury
Peterson's friends family and legal
teams celebrated the verdict and moments
later he told the Press quote I've got
my life back only person to blame was
that monster Peterson who could have
faced nearly 100 years in prison if
convicted placed sole blame on the
gunman for the 2018 Parkland shooting
three adults and 14 teenagers were
killed prosecutors had argued that
Peterson who was the only armed school
resource officer on duty that day
ignored his training to confront the
gunman instead he remained outside the
building for more than 40 minutes
Peterson's attorney said he could not
tell where the shots were coming from